thank you
[Music]
so there's this movie that's in
pre-production it's called Elena of Cuba
Elena of Cuba Alina is the daughter of
Fidel Castro oh how do you spell that
that's my sister's name oh yeah that's
exactly like my sister's name oh my gosh
dude 212 spelling what's another way to
do it like with the e
uh I don't know if he's pronouncing
Elena Elena Alina Selena s Alina Castro
Alina Castro so it's Castro's daughter
yeah she's the Communist queen of Cuba
that's a fire title communist so it's
it's really that's what the movie is
about the queen of Cuban sandwiches but
um
even though John leg was almost not
associated with his film at all he's
pretty pissed about the casting really
why because they didn't cast him no
because they cast somebody else as uh
Fidel Castro who's not even Latino what
Pedro Pascal
keep it
um Oscar Isaac Denzel Washington
Samuel Jackson that would probably be
better he's a famous guy who's Pedro is
that the Mandalorian guy can you imagine
yeah Denzel's
what about the dude from uh uh um the
new uh
Star Wars thing and um did someone say
Oscar Isaac yeah whatever his name is
yeah what's his name [ __ ] it's not that
guy who is also in narcos Mexico wasn't
he
I don't remember so he's not I think lad
is it Shia LaBeouf
who actually looks like Castro though
you don't think this guy looks like
Castro
he kind of does actually what the he
does actually though he does holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
holy ghosts
yeah
you have to be he kind of looks like
he's out here look it's first of my
brain recognized James Franco and then I
looked I'm like oh
James Castro he should be voiced by John
Legend what about what about uh that's
not even in makeup to look like cats
it's just like that's just how he looks
wait we got Luigi [ __ ] hating on this
guy
it was a good Luigi man come on hey this
is okay Luigi but he wasn't Italian
right John leg was almost that's not an
Italian name that's true he could pass
is he Cuban I think he's Puerto Rican
something like that I thought he was
just Mexican my bad I think he's Puerto
Rican he had no right to play in Italian
plumber is what I'm saying because he's
from New York or some [ __ ] because
remember on to Wong Fu he's like I got
more legs than a bucket of chicken and
then he was like
something like that he's probably Puerto
Rican yeah yeah maybe yeah
so John link is almost like a huge pest
advocate for like you know Latino
representation in Hollywood and so he's
speaking up about this he's pretty
pissed that uh this one he said
something like how is this still
happening that's his like wait I'm
confused because
maybe I don't know too much about like
the Latin X world but the way I view the
way I view you don't like that [ __ ] but
okay but the way I view I view South
America right it's just like I feel like
it's still European but with mixed
indigenous okay because there's black
Latin there's white Latin there's like
yeah because like there were French
people Spanish people there's Asian
Latin too yeah and then I just feel like
it's a Spanish-speaking American country
right so like I don't understand
technically the South American country
but shouldn't he if he's going to be uh
Fidel shouldn't he be a Cuban I think
this is what yeah but Fidel I don't even
know if he's Cuban well because so
embarrassed so this is the history is so
the history is they're uh Central or
Mexican-American and they went to Cuba
to liberate Cuba but they're all Latino
so some of these guys weren't born in
Cuba
like he might be I think Colombian or
whatever but him in Che Guevara went to
Cuba to liberate it
I don't think I think his gripe is that
he's Franco's not even Latino at all do
you think he's got a guard that like
armas is playing Marilyn Monroe
I do yeah Steve does what do you think
of that [ __ ] ouch hey what do you think
what do you think that [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying though it's like a
little bit of a two-way street like for
example I heard um Samuel L Jackson I
heard uh also got upset at uh what's his
face uh the guy who does nope and uh
um Jordan peel because if you're going
to cast uh somebody for the
African-American experience but he casts
somebody that's like a an actual person
from Africa an African yeah you know of
what's the Immigrant African American
yeah it's also not doing the same thing
so I know that like in those you know
when we're talking about it's funny
because you look at like Europeans right
when we look like white people we don't
we don't call them Europeans we're gonna
say they're Germans or there's something
to write but then you look at like
Asians and you don't like people don't
go like you're Japanese you're the
everybody's just is Asian we don't go by
continents yeah so in the same concept
right I understand that there's it's
just a double-edged sword but if we do a
little bit
of American Jackie Chan's Asian I've
seen other people usually look at us and
they just cause Asian you guys ask each
other what you are you know what I mean
like that that happens Nikki all the
[ __ ] time what do you mean you guys
bro you I mean you people
yeah when I saw annadaramus play Marilyn
Monroe I was like interesting right but
if I mean if the guy that looks like
Fidel Castro is going to play Fidelity
he looks [ __ ] like Fidel Castro dude
I think what makes you different is that
they're like Marilyn Monroe's always
been played by someone white so then
it's like oh at least let's just get one
where it's not maybe
the armist she's white or not white she
Brown she's not she brown girl let me
push back a little bit so you guys watch
Pam and Tommy right yes I did it there's
a somewhere somewhere there's a there's
a busty blonde actress who can't get a
[ __ ] job in Hollywood because they
took this chick and they put Prosthetics
all over her body
she's a brunette she's not like she
doesn't have [ __ ] Double D's she's
she's not like Pam Anderson looking so
they took her and they actually made her
look more like Pam Anderson using
Prosthetics and they could have just
used the blonde there's some busty
blonde actors out there who's [ __ ]
eating at Denny's tonight because she
can't get a [ __ ] job in Hollywood
because this chick [ __ ] took her and
she's skipping on the bill because it's
too expensive she's walking on it she's
[ __ ] dying in the ditches stealing
moons over my hammy he goes this is just
what's called acting you know what I
mean you know like this is just acting
like you're James Franco You're Gonna
Act and be a Cuban man yeah okay that's
another thing too he's like if no one
ever seen eating a Cuban sandwich like
Fidel what like what's the alternative
that people want a perfectly cast film
that ends up sucking ass and they won't
even see it they honestly would be way
happier with that hey yeah did you guys
see morbius
[Music]
um so Jared Leto he pretended to be in a
wheelchair like the whole [ __ ] time
right but then even between takes he
would make everyone wait like 45 minutes
for him to do bathroom breaks because he
wanted to like take his wheelchair out
of the bathroom dude it's more BS dog
and then that movie ended up like
sucking complete dick yeah because he
spent too much time to go to the
bathroom yeah everyone thinks that movie
completely sucks because he went to
method on it but that's the thing it's
like you know these people are still
doing a business they're still making a
movie that has to sell I'm also confused
about like the idea of what is white
because then like so like all right
Cameron Diaz to me she looks like a
white girl but she's not right she's lat
Latino
so I think for that she widest for Latin
people I forgot what the term was I
think it's actually like mestizo or
something but the actual Latin like
group that they identify with or what
they're who they're fighting for are
partial Spanish blood partial
auditioners but Castro looks like a
Spanish man well here's what Leguizamo
actually he looks like
oh that that that mestizo whatever like
is what they're going after what is it
John Leguizamo is a hypocrite dog why
you playing he played a Chinese man in
the movie pest he played a [ __ ]
Chinese delivery man and he did a very
strong accent like this ping I think and
it's one of my favorite movies
I love that movie the past the past yeah
it's Annie played in Italian where she
has no [ __ ] right so who are you John
that's that's what I think he's saying
when he says House Hollywood like how is
this still going on it's like he knows
that he was a part of something that
should be expired by now does he I I
think so he doesn't do that anymore yeah
you know like that was all the 90 [ __ ]
that everybody he said for my sage so
would he be happier if it was [ __ ]
like George Lopez who looks nothing like
him honestly yes he would probably
there's nothing like Fidel Castro but he
is Latino [ __ ] it that'd be a good take
that's why I wish we could just go into
alternate like timelines just to see
what people would say because I feel
like some people will hate no matter who
you put in that spot they're just gonna
go oh you could have found a better girl
oh you could have found this remember
when um Squadron Hansel was gonna be
this like trans person and who's also
going to be Asian too oh Ghost in the
Shell right what's the show she was
Asian but Scott Johansson
the way that they the way that they find
budgets for these movies is they attach
dollars to a name yeah they know they
can sell it in this market right so like
that that nature breaks the movie makes
it breaks the movie so they were going
to take a story about this trans person
and then but then because Scarlett
Johansson is a straight woman they're
like like everyone came out backlash
backlash and then they canceled it and
she's like yeah fine [ __ ] it I won't be
this way no it doesn't exist you don't
even get this trans story you can hold
there's no earmark dollars towards some
Rando who is that person it's just that
you now have nuked that story out of
existence so that story doesn't get told
now yeah yeah so that's what um but then
with this one because because this is
like a Cuban historical figure you know
that's what he's pissed about he said
how is Hollywood excluding us but
stealing our narratives as well you know
that's the difference so I like The Last
Samurai right and I was just like but
here we go again with the last of the
[ __ ] Mohicans white Washington fake
ass story right and then I researched it
and there's actually three white
samurais yeah there's there's a British
guy AI he he got knighted um he became a
Samurai and they just and there's a
french guy that went to Japan to teach
them how to uh shoot and then and then
they they yeah and then they they ended
up being
um they ended up being um um um like
accepted by Japanese and then they
became Samurai all the [ __ ] they were
knighted so I was like oh [ __ ] so that's
an interesting story and then they just
Blended all of those stories
Santa please
so after that I was like oh [ __ ] that's
kind of cool I can't get mad at it
anymore you know because I thought what
they did was some [ __ ] Dances with
Wolves [ __ ] on us it's also not like
there's no Samurai movies with all
Asians like it's a [ __ ] million of
them do you guys remember one with a
white guy that's like that bad like not
really do you guys remember scary movie
when uh yeah I love scary movie right we
all love scary movie
no
there's a part where what's her name
sees like Chris Pratt's ex-wife oh yeah
she sees the [ __ ] she's this little
ghost and he's like all right Japanese
woman Grudge ghost and then yeah the
joke is that they're like like this is
like this is a white lady and so she
doesn't know like this is probably how
how Asian people talk and so she's like
she's like Hiroshima Nagasaki Samurai
Toyota Honda
you say the same [ __ ] back to her like
usually just all trophy [ __ ] yeah all
Japanese brand names
how dare you